President Vladimir zielinski returns to
Ukraine claiming another successful
overseas Mission and leaving turkey with
an added prize five soldiers who led the
resistance at the azov steel Works in
mariupole and considered war heroes by
most ukrainians
after their surrender to Russian forces
they were released as part of a prisoner
exchange on the apparent understanding
they would sit out the war in Turkey but
were now on the same plane as their
President coming home
zelenski had been meeting with President
Rajiv tayap erdogan who has been playing
a key mediating role in this war
maintaining strong relations with Moscow
while supporting Ukraine's bid for NATO
membership
Ukraine deserves NATO membership I'd
like to emphasize a point I've always
defended persistently a fair peace
creates no losers
held talks about the renewal of the deal
that allows the export of Ukrainian
grain across the Black Sea which runs
out in little more than a week and which
Russia has been reluctant to renew
today we are focused on how the
leadership of turkey and your leadership
president erdogan can help restore peace
and normal International order where the
interest of all are balanced
zelenski returns to Kiev with his forces
locked in Fierce fighting on all fronts
as Ukraine's counter-offensive grinds on
all of this is happening as Ukraine
marks the 500th day of this war with a
special video from president zielinski
hailing his country's military and
seemingly reaffirming his position as
the figurehead for Ukraine's continued
resistance
he coincided with the release of another
richly symbolic video a visit by
zelenski to snake island that was seized
by Russian forces on the first day of
the war but later retaken by Ukrainian
troops
a small island says the lensky in the
commentary but to him proof that all
Ukrainian land will one day be regained
Robert McBride Al Jazeera Keith